am i a grown man talking about a show
about fairies
you're goddamn right netflix's fate the
wink saga is a live-action adaptation of
the 2004 nickelodeon show
winx club and its 2016 successor world
of winx
[Music]
but you know netflix has to go all cw on
us and has turned this 17 year old kids
show into a brooding fantasy teen drama
think of it like taking the care bears
and turning them into horny emotional
teens
in this video we'll be uncovering some
of the show's biggest secrets and what
it could mean for season two so sprout
some fiery fairy wings and make sure to
like and subscribe because here we
go welcome to alphea no not you alf an
elite boarding school for fairies and
combat soldiers known as specialists
it's located in solaria one of
otherworld's seven realms which is under
the control of queen luna we'll get to
that piece of work in a bit
meet bloom the show's protagonist you
might remember the actress abigail cowan
here as one of the weird sisters dorkas
from
chilling adventures of sabrina bloom
isn't like the other kids being the only
student from
earth which they call the first world
her journey this season sees her
struggling to harness her powers while
uncovering her secret past
in episode 1 bloom finds out that she's
a changeling that she was switched at
birth and doesn't know who her real
parents are this is where we find her at
the beginning of the final episode her
search for answers has led her to
rosalin one of the most powerful fairies
ever who was imprisoned in headmistress
dowling's undercroft
and in her quest for answers bloom
decides to let her free and that's
because
dowling and the other staff haven't been
telling the truth about bloom's past
they lie about her real parents and hide
her from the atrocity that occurred at
astor del
astor del was a village under siege by
the burned ones fire creatures which
seek to destroy the fairies we'll get to
them in their connection to bloom in a
bit
rosalind told the others that the town
had been evacuated but
that was a lie they ended up being
complicit in a massacre which killed all
the burned ones
and many innocent lives when the other
teachers found about this they
imprisoned rosalind as bloom learns this
story
may not be true she learns from roslyn
that the town was inhabited by
blood witches they were humans who drew
on sacrifice and death
blood witches these blood witches kidnap
bloom as a baby from her real fairy
parents
likely to be given to the burned ones
the burn ones want bloom because she
possesses an ancient primal power
known as the dragonflame if they can
kill her before she's grown up and
learns to harness this power it would
eliminate their biggest threat this is
why rosalind put bloom on earth to be
raised by earth parents it was the
safest place for her to be now you might
be asking yourself if bloom was switched
at birth
where did that other baby go that human
baby well we're not 100
sure but we do know that that human
child had a heart defect and wasn't
expected to live long
it probably didn't make it so when
rosalind did the switch it was a win-win
had a heart defect in the womb but a day
after i was born it was gone
for rosalind she was killing two birds
with one stone eliminating a bunch of
burned ones and blood witches in one go
but what we don't know is if she's
telling the truth and i think there's
more to this astor del story and what it
means for bloom's past to be discovered
in season 2. so bloom ends up freeing
rosalind in exchange for knowledge on
where she came from but rosalind says
she can't use her magic until she's
recharged at the stone circle the stone
circle is a conduit to all the magical
energy which flows throughout the realm
here your powers can be heightened which
is why many of the students lessons are
conducted here when rosalind recharges
however she ends up sucking up so much
power that the magical barrier
protecting alfie from the burned ones
shuts off as well as all the magic
powered lights which illuminate its
halls
this is all part of rosalind's plan she
wants the burn ones to attack alfie in
an attempt to test bloom to use her
powers and show her true nature
that she is a descendant of the
dragonflame that's why when bloom gets a
text saying the school is under attack
that rosalind doesn't come with her
bloom needs to do this by herself to
prove that she is the chosen one
these revelations also mean that bloom's
fairy parents
may still be alive i don't think we've
seen them in the show yet but i imagine
much of season 2 will be her searching
for them and learning how she was
kidnapped by the blood witches
after all rosalind did promise when all
this is over she'll help her find her
birth parents
and when this is over we'll find your
birth parents
together meanwhile alfie's resident bad
boy riven finds dane healing his
girlfriend beatrix after she was thrown
into dowling's undercroft spell trap
ironic since she was the one to push
callum into it earlier on in the season
beatrix has filled the role of villain
for much of the season doing everything
she can to uncover dowling's secrets
in her mind however she thinks she's
doing good she believes dowling has
wrongfully imprisoned rosalind that
dowling and the other teachers are the
evil ones
and that dowling is responsible for her
adoptive father having to live in hiding
for 16 years one of the big reveals at
the end of the season
is that beatrix's father is andreas of
uraculos
a legendary specialist who we thought
was killed by silva during the events of
astardell andreas and silva fought after
silva found out rosalind was going to
destroy the town
knowing it would kill innocents andreas
however was following orders
andreas you have a choice
your orders all your morals this was one
of the most painful things silva had to
do
kill his best friend in order to stop
hundreds from dying
this is why he pays so much attention to
skye andreas
son becoming a father-like figure to him
and silva ends up telling sky the truth
that he was the one to kill his father
but as we learn at the end andreas is
still alive beatrix was raised by him
however he's not her real father
technically he's not my dad but he'll
know what to do this revelation is so
emotional for skye that he spends the
entire night and
into the morning contemplating things on
the front lawn of alfie how is andreas
going to justify
being away from his son and raising
another child andreas probably had no
choice for fear of being discovered
hence why he had to have his adoptive
daughter do all the dirty work
in our side story sam and earth fairy
was viciously attacked by a burned one
if you're cut by a burned one it
unleashes a lethal toxin which can't be
stopped unless the burned one which
caused it
is killed sam and musa the mind fairy
developed a relationship over the season
and because she's an empath can take
away some of his pain this is hard for
her because
the last time she did it was with her
dying mother and taking away sam's pain
will dig up the emotions she felt about
her mother's death emotions
she said she never wants to feel again
but she man's up and does it buying sam
enough time until the burned one that
attacked him is killed of all the powers
this season
muses was the one i felt has the most
potential to grow in season two
we haven't seen the extent of what she
can do and i bet there's a lot more
powers that she can unlock
like reading minds not just feelings
mind control
manipulating thoughts i'm excited to see
what the writers will come up with
as the teachers and students await the
burned ones attack they are surprised
when their attackers change course
they're all moving together like they're
following something that's because
they're after bloom
she leads them outside where we get to
finally see the true extent of her
ancient magic
the magic of the dragonflame she sprouts
flame wings
wings being something fairies haven't
had in centuries well we had wings in
the past
as we've evolved transformation magic
has been lost and she makes quick work
of the burned ones destroying their
cinders the magical core which powers
them
inside each burned one is a magical core
called a cinder and with time and
finesse you can use your magic
to destroy it but look at the bodies
left over from the burned ones they're
human dressed in medieval chain-linked
armor as rosalind tells dowling the
burned ones were once humans from an
ancient war a thousand years ago it was
an
ancient magic that created them this
magic is called the dragonflame and it
burns
inside bloom this is why the burned ones
are attracted to her and likely explains
why bloom always hears whispers every
time she's around a burned one
rosalind tells dalling that a war is
coming and that bloom's powers will be
needed
only through rosalind's teaching can
bloom fully unlock and harness that
power
but in order to teach bloom roslin must
get rid of dowling and become the new
headmistress
killing dowling and collaborating with
queen luna to get the job queen luna we
learned was involved in the cover-up of
astor del and had a major dislike for
dowling so she approved rosalind
becoming the new headmistress bloom goes
back home and knows she has to tell her
parents the truth
she knows how lies and what withholding
information can lead to
so she thinks it's best she tells her
parents who she really is
and they seem pretty accepting but it's
not until the girls arrive back at
school that they find there's been a few
changes welcome back ladies
there have been a few changes and this
shot of andreas rosalin and queen luna
really sets up what the major conflicts
will be for next season first we have
the introduction of andreas and what
that means for both sky
silva and beatrix skye will likely want
to reconnect with his father and
who knows what that means for this new
pseudo-sister beatrix
silva and andreas will have bad blood
which will likely turn violent and then
there's queen
luna i don't think she'll be staying at
alfia but will return here and there
when needed but the fact the queen of
celeria is backing this new headmistress
probably means that roslyn will lean
into the queen's preferred
method of education tough love as stella
says of her mother's teachings
project strength and power
never show weakness when positive
emotions didn't work
she went right to the negative
hard then there's rosalind who will
likely be teaming up with bloom to
harness her powers
i wouldn't be surprised if rosalind
wants those powers for herself and if
there's a way that can be achieved
rosalind more than any other fairy knows
about ancient magics
she was the one to discover that fairies
can combine their powers together to
create stronger magics her desire to
help bloom find her real parents is
likely a facade in order for something
more sinister
rosalind definitely has something up her
sleeve and it probably spells bad news
for bloom
what i'm really excited for is how
dowling said fairies may be able to
harness
multiple elements further down the line
you may learn to connect with other
elements but your first year is all
about the element you were born with
imagine bloom being able to channel fire
air mind earth and
others all at once if there's a
dragonflame does that mean there are
other ancient magics for the other
elements that
fairies can harness and with a war on
the horizon rosalind says the burned
ones are nothing compared to what's
coming bloom was easily able to take on
those burn ones so
next season we'll need a new even more
dangerous foe
perhaps someone who leads the burned
ones we know that bloom is somehow
connected with the burned ones
could the mystery of her parents have
something to do with this ancient war
thousands of years ago
could her parents somehow be involved
with the burned ones i wouldn't be
surprised if the main villain next
season ends up being one of her parents
or
ancestors and i just want to bring this
up briefly but on imdb it states that
bloom's earth mother is credited as
vanessa dowling now this could just be a
mistake but if it's true that could
being bloom's adoptive mother
is head mistress dowling's daughter i'm
not sure how that works but i just found
it very interesting
either way it looks like next year
althea will be filled with
even more magic and drama thanks for
watching everyone
what did you think of the season i want
to hear your thoughts and theories below
make sure to like and subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram
think story yt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much